[Musik]
es sind eine beule stockdunkle nacht das
sitzen auf einem baum und vor uns
entfalten sich unglaubliche szenen
unglaublich wie die dunkelheit hier im
raum
das ist abenteuer pur
uns menschen ist die nacht seit jeher
fremd
die sechsteilige netflix serie david
malt die erde bei nach zu deutsch die
wir alles opulente großartige
fantastische aus der größten aller
naturdoku fabriken der welt der bbc
kommt wie man hört hat die bbc so viel
mittel wie nie eingesetzt um diese
fünfjährige produktion auf die beine zu
stellen und das sieht man in jeder
aufnahme eben schnitt mit low light
technologien und wärmebildkameras kann
man zehn in der nacht sichtbar machen
für die man nicht mal das fahle licht
des mondes braucht und das ist
unglaublich das zu sehen
man muss wirklich kein fan von taylor
swift sein um den die dokumentation bis
amerikaner interessant zu finden
und ich bin auch kein fan von taylor
swift aber das was ich da gesehen habe
war eigentlich eine art amerikanische
[Musik]
diese dokumentation zeigt wirklich sehr
schön und sehr beispielhaften aus einem
netten kranken mädchen von nebenan ein
feministischer popstar wird und eben
auch die bedingungen von außen und das
schöne ist dass taylor swift darüber
sehr reflektiert reden kann und sich
selbst dabei auch sehr kritisch sieht
und ihr vergangen ich auch sehr kritisch
sieht ihre ihr bedürfnis immer gemocht
zu werden und wie sich daraus gearbeitet
hat zeigt müsse man kann sehr schön ist
wirklich ausgesprochen interessant und
auch für nicht-fans öffnet das so ein
stück amerika also es ist nicht nur eine
musik doku sondern die doch wirklich
weit darüber hinaus wenn euch
interessiert was eigentlich ein trainer
seiner mannschaft in der halbzeitpause
sagt was eigentlich bei
vertragsgesprächen mit profisportlern
gesprochen wird
und vor allem was eigentlich in den
köpfen der menschen vor sich geht die
glauben ihr lebensglück hänge einzig und
allein mit ihrer körperlichen
leistungsfähigkeit zusammen dann
empfehle ich euch die doku-reihe oder
nach den auf amazon
[Applaus]
weder tore gebettelt dieses format wurde
mit dem emmy ausgezeichnet und stellt
jedes jahr ein neues team der nfl also
der besten fußball liga der welt vor und
verfolgt die spieler die trainer die
betreuer mit mehreren kameras auf
schritt und tritt
kameras hängen in jedem konferenzzimmer
kameras sind bei jeder besprechung dabei
kameras dokumentieren wie dieses team
funktioniert es ist also eine art big
brother in echten sport leben meine
empfehlung ist ein sportfilm ich gebe
mein tipp hier mit worum es gehen könnte
ein kletter film es geht um free solo
und da geht es um ein ziemlich harmlos
wirkenden klettern alex rosenthal ist er
aber wirkt der macht die krasseste
sportart im klettern die man sich so
vorstellen kann die gefährlichste
nämlich ohne seil ohne sicherung ohne
irgendwas zu klettern auch nicht kein
falscher mix klettert er da und wenn er
loslässt oder fällt aus irgendeinem
grund dann ist es vorbei mit leben und
für den film free solo hat er sich ein
ganz ganz extremes projekt ausgesucht er
will nämlich den l kapital das ist einer
der berühmtesten kletter massive der
welt das ist im yosemite valley in
amerika und da will auf fast 1000 meter
hoch klettern ein projekt für das er
sich sehr sehr lange vorbereiten muss
aber der film versucht so ein bisschen
dahinter zu gucken was steckt dahinter
was geht in seinem kopf vor und was
passiert auch mit seiner umgebung
vereinen
man kriegt schwitzige hände beim
zuschauen
man kriegt einen tiefen einblick in den
kopf eines ich würde mal sagen
wahnsinnigen und und kam dabei einfach
seine umgebung mal für einen kurzen
zeitraum völlig völlig vergessen alle
ganz toll dokumentation superstars im
zweifel morgens bürger darum mörder der
im ersten teil schon mit 30 tagen
eigentlich fast ein eigenes passwort
fest ob auf bundes total spannend weil
er dabei unter anderem die marketing
liegt sie fast betrieben ist verstimmt
rubicon die krone und nebenbei auch noch
auf deck wie der gefühle handel in den
usa vom prinzip nur von einem täter
neben gesteuert wird und dabei auch
durch patrick es ist ganz überraschend
teilweise auch lustig aber auch sehr
ernst und bringt vielleicht eine rücken
meine zu den eigenen konsum und passt
gut zu überdenken wenn noch nicht
gesehen hat dem kann ich glücklich
meinen empfehlen
das ist ein dokumentarfilm von werner
herzog darin geht es um tim ist die
travel einen tierschutzaktivisten oder
hobby tierfilmer der 13 sommer lang in
alaska bei grizzlybären verbracht hat
bis er dann so viel sei verraten eines
tages auch von dem bären gefressen wird
ich habe mir in der bits and pieces der
thematik virtuell hat hunderte stunden
an material in der wildnis gefilmt und
werner herzog nimmt diese aufnahmen und
zeichnet anhand der aufnahmen ein bild
ein psychogramm von travel wo man am
ende zum schluss kommen dass das
eingesessene ein getriebener
er fasst ein irrer war die komplexe und
was man feststellen kann ist wenn man
sich diese aufnahme von travel ansieht
ist dass diese grenze zwischen mensch
und tier bei ihm immer mehr verschwommen
ist auch werner herzog kommt am ende zu
dem schluss dass dritte vielleicht gar
kein mensch mehr sein wollte sondern
sich viel eher den bergen zugehörig
gefühlt hat und diese reise gepard vor
allem mit den bildern nach diesem film
einfach unfassbar sehenswert ich bin
viele caniza schatten von ulrike
ottinger deutsche avantgarde künstlerin
eigentlich ist
dieses jahr auf der berlinale mit der
berlinale kamera für ihr lebenswerk
ausgezeichnet worden also für ihr
schaffen und sie ist eben nicht nur aber
gar künstlerin sondern auch
ethnographische schon immer interessiert
gewesen und für diesen film war sie 2015
in der beringsee unterwegs hat sich also
von alaska bis nach kamtschatka
angeguckt wie die indigenen völker dort
leben und wie die menschen dort mit der
natur klarkommen und ihr leben gestalten
und das besondere an dem film ist sie
macht das in der tradition von alexander
von humboldt von adalbert von kam nie so
diesen ganzen forschern des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts und wie auch sie hat sie
einen sehr offenen sehr neugierigen
blick mit dem sie sich anguckt was sie
dort sieht elf stunden lang also das
heißt das nimmt einem wirklich komplett
mit ist eine komplett eigene reise und
man ist für diese elf stunden in einer
komplett anderen welt
ich empfehle die formel 1 dokumentation
drive to survive auch als nicht
formel-1-fan fand ich die doku sehr
interessant einfach weil sie sich nicht
die ganze zeit um diesen ewigen
zweikampf zwischen lewis hamilton und
sebastian vettel dreht sondern vielmehr
die fahrer mechaniker und manager der
unteren teams zu wort kommen und man
sehr gute eindrücke bekommt wie diese
teams mit dem ewigen druck mit dem
konkurrenzkampf auch im eigenen team
umgehen und wie sie ja quasi um die
existenz kämpfen teilweise insgesamt
muss man sagen ist drives verwarf
natürlich nichts mit dem man bei einem
intellektuellen treff bestechen kann
dafür ist es einfach eine viel zu
leichte doku aber gerade in diesen tagen
kann ich diese doku eigentlich nur
empfehlen weil man sie auch getrost auch
mal nebenbei laufen lassen kann wenn man
gerade mit kochen bügeln oder wäsche
aufhängen beschäftigt ist